جريمه مروعه شهدتها هابيلو وضحيتها امراه
مكسيكيه تعرفت على شاب بين عبر الانترنت
ووقعت في حبه وسافر من المكسيك الى بيرو
للقائه لتنقطع اخبارها ويعثر عليها مقتوله
لاحقا
وسائل الاعلام عالميه قالت ان السلطات في
بيروح عثرت على الاعضاء الخارجيه لجسم
بلانكا ارلانو التي تبلغ من العمر واحد
وخمسين عاما مرميه في البحر بعد ما قدمت
اسرتها بلاغ عن اختفائها
[موسيقى]
في ما اكدت السلطات طريقه المتهم بعضا من
اعضائها الداخليه والقت السلطات القبض على
المتهم بقتلها اخوان بابلو الذي يبلغ من
العمر 37 عاما بتهمه تهريب الاعضاء
البشريه حيث نشر اخوان مقاطع فيديو على
تطبيق التيك توك تظهره وهو يقوم بتشريح
اعضاء بشريه بما في ذلك البنكرياس والدماغ
[موسيقى]